you guys have been real good
yeah very very nice and much appreciated
so
uh i have something for you
i have something for you
new dayton hypernova we have a new
dayton hypernova video folks barbarian
here on day wave
would have premiered in rotc yesterday
but someone's going to do a show so
we're doing it here
and we might play an rtc this afternoon
as well but uh you get the exclusive
first look at the new dayton hypernova
video
that's right folks that's right there
is right now hot off the presses
a new dayton hypernova
video and that calls for
wait everyone's happy till i hit play
all right let's check it out
dayton hypernova title of this video you
guys know the title
my arrogant big abusive mom my employer
being physically violent to me visibly
on
then it cuts off back through
to check on your mouth i know that
someone put it out earlier
it's not a horse blanket i don't think i
don't think that's a horse blanket
here we go to check
on your money hey all right
now we paid you the week we left
so that one we gave you the money you
didn't pay me
i paid you november the week
why are you even paying him he's living
in
your house why are you paying him
it ended november 4th you were paid
because we paid you
before we left so that's when we won't
you wash your blanket it's disgusting
not back so there's you didn't pay me
for a weekend then
after we got back would be the 13th the
20th
27th and the fifth this week is the 11th
okay so i paid you a hundred dollar bill
i paid you that on the week and that's
that covers one of them okay
then i gave you a hundred and eighty
dollars this is why you pay on time
i paid you this is why you pay uh
i really need a screaming pillow in here
i i really do
i i i mean i mean this is why you you're
living there for free
and they're throwing you a couple bucks
to wash clothes this is why you pay on
time
this is why you pay on time
what
on the week uh that's that covers one of
them
okay then i gave you
this a hundred you pay on time i paid
you a hundred and eighty dollars because
i subtracted 20.
that's not even the point would you stop
so you can
understand what's being told you you
cannot hear when you speak
i see a narcissist
did he call her a narcissist
did he call her a narcissist
as a man of dating ohio i'm sorry i i
don't accept your apology and i mean i
appreciate it but i don't accept it
um
did he call her a narcissist
it's narcissa you're talking about a lot
i don't know why you're not getting paid
you want to know
do you want to know do you want to know
why you're not being paid
leda pal drake is not happy with him
take the picture and post it take the
picture and tell them
this is why you're not being paid i just
checked my credit talk to me what are
you talking about i just checked my
credit card
so who is lopeza mom i ordered things
online for my 3d
camera
he orders things online for his 3d
camera he orders things online for his
3d camera but that money shouldn't be
taken out when it's time for him to get
paid
he uses their credit card to order
things online
for his 3d camera because right now what
he needs to work on
is his 3d camera so you can see
what what a big piece of [ __ ] he is in
every dimension
do you know how much i adore you guess
what i don't owe you a lot
i want to say one thing i want to say
guess
how much i don't know i don't know why
do you want to hear me you want to know
do you want to know how much i don't
know why do you not want to you
you you i don't know
i'm here to remind you
that you're a leech of your parents
when i'm here to remind you
you should have moved out ten years ago
you you you gotta go
sorry i apologize
for you oh my god i'm telling you 966
mom they asked me ask me what 966
dollars is
what's 966 dollars dayton ask me ask me
right now
what's 966 dollars dayton
no i'm not even gonna i'm telling you
this 966 dollars mom what is it you want
to
know why you're not being paid do you
want to know
dude [ __ ] oh the living
punch right in his stupid face do it
punch him right in his stupid face
boom boom
[Laughter]
do you want to know you are one foot
away from my face
yes get it get it queen
you take him out oh oh
yeah [ __ ] yeah yes
boom go for it no
do you want to know you are one foot
away from my face
do you want to know do you want to know
if you why are you physically
violent shut your mouth do you know that
your skinhead son
is the reason he's this way yeah but the
skinhead son's not running up credit
card debt and then bitching about not
getting paid on youtube
you can call the police why am i getting
an argument about the police about this
i'm not being physical towards you you
are hitting me get out of the house
you want to know why do you have a
meltdown
do you what why is she having a meltdown
are you [ __ ] kidding me right now
what you know why are you having this
manic crazed eye
look at your she's manic
shut your mouth you need to be
respectful to a
person in your home i don't give a [ __ ]
if you were a [ __ ]
turkey i'm gonna respect you your
pronouns mean nothing to me
dayton they mean absolutely nothing i
don't care what adjectives you use
before your name
because the only adjective you should
use before your name is
shitty dating hypernova because that's
what you are you're a shitty person
your genitals and your gender have
nothing to do
with what a piece of human garbage you
are
and you are a piece of human garbage
call the police why am i doing that to
come and get you what does this have to
do with it
here mom i just want to have a decent
sane conversation i want
i can't tell you what i want
i can't tell you what i want
i can't say i hope he's a big nirvana
fan
i could say that and he goes
i'm not fighting with you because you
have an idiot
you don't know how to even talk talk
record it because the police watch
everything you
look at his old [ __ ] 80s hi okay hey
hold on let's let's examine the uh
the dresser here so we have like
a wreck of a record slash tape player
from the 80s
pepsi even though he eats health
burritos he's gonna have a pepsi
a wine glass a champagne flute now that
wine goes a champagne flute
uh a wine bottle
looks like one two three different types
of cough syrup
maybe she could make lean and then a
variety of belts hanging from his
dresser
so what it looks like a variety of belts
you do mom there's nothing you can do
there is
nothing you can do monitor the police
monitor him huh
there is nothing your crazy sounding ass
is going to be
your crazy southern ass you've lived
with her your entire life what is your
ass
i want to hear it 96.30 i know exactly
how much i charge credit cards
and guess what i make 100 a week from
you so that's not even a whole week
guess yes yes that's not even a whole
week but
you're still using your credit card
dayton how much
i don't owe you 966 dollars
and you're not gonna ask what i mean by
that
no because you're a liar dayton
because you are so proud of your money
and not the god you pretend to worship
you just like in god we trust on your
money that's all you care about
and you love to shout at people that you
think
are smaller than you when really you're
the one mentally and emotionally
very small you're living in her house
you
piece [ __ ] that's the end of the video
you're living in her house you piece of
[ __ ]
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] we were all
happy
you remember earlier how happy we were
about having new dating and stuff
you remember do you remember how happy
we were
it's it's it's bad date hypernova videos
are an abusive relationship with us guys
we watch them and then we're like why
why are we
why did we watch these things
i'm bringing it up to the main show
obviously but
what the [ __ ] man
yeah his brother lives there too oh
somebody knows doesn't know the date and
hyper and over lore
you want to learn the lore by the way
just i'll help you out here
uh just search uh dayton hypernova
revenge of the sys
it'll come up there's a couple on rotc
clips too just to plug uh
youtube.com rotc media that's rtclips
channel that's the one that uh
one-legged ag luck is running
there's some there if you're really
behind i i don't have time to explain
the
it's a lot it's the lore runs deep with
dayton
okay